the people that came before us are not
our masters they're our teachers there
are guides but if i find a new way to
proceed that it's better
i'll do it because you know the truth it
says is open to all
and and will be uncovered by future
generations
twice in a year what a tree i know
[Laughter]
well you know it's the pandemic it's
easier to get people
stuck at home that's true well we've got
nothing else to do we might as well just
keep on talking about stoicism
the stoic the stoic guide to a happy
life
53 brief brief lessons for living why'd
you write this
for two reasons on the one hand there's
kind of a personal reason
the the book is really a ambitious to
some extent rewriting of the enkei
reading which is one of the classic
texts in stories is engine stories and
and in its uh it wasn't written by epic
theaters
uh but it uh it is about epictetus
teaching
epithelials didn't write anything um and
uh one of his
best students or most famous student
aryan and nicomedia
uh right wrote down both the discourses
and in caridian
to some extent this is my personal
homage to epictetus because
he has been my study guide throughout my
stoic path um you know i love all of
these stoics i read marcus already i
read seneca i read some of the so-called
minor stoics that are not really minor
they're just minor because we don't have
a hell of a lot
uh that survived of his of of their
writings but epictetus has been the one
that really got me into it
and it has been sort of a constant
companion so into one ex
in one sense it is just a my personal
homage to epictetus
but more importantly it is an attempt to
update stoicism and in particular
epithelius version of stoicism to the
21st century
and the reason for that is that stoicism
in a sense got interrupted uh you know
it started out in uh the late fourth
century bce
it flourished for five or six centuries
until the early third century of the
modern era
and then it kind of got interrupted by
christianity just like every other
uh you know hellenistic philosophy just
like it disappear from
from view and in that sense
the greek roman philosophies are very
different from let's say a number of
eastern traditions such as buddhism and
confucianism taoism
which evolved and developed gradually
over time in essentially uninterrupted
fashion
so for instance if you compare stoicism
with buddhism
today it's not even correct really to
talk about buddhism in the singular
there are many buddhisms right because
there's number of traditions that
evolved over continuously over two and a
half millennia
and clearly nobody today is a buddhist
in the same sense in which somebody was
a buddhist two thousand
and you know and a half uh you know
years ago
but that's not true for stoicism because
it's like after the third
the the second or third centuries like
we we have a lot of influence of
stoicism on other thinkers like
christian writers throughout the middle
ages and the renaissance and you know
early modern philosophers
but then we kind of have a jump to the
20th century essentially
and so um i'm not the first one to do
this kind of thing
the thing my friend and colleague larry
baker who wrote a new stoicism
uh did a similar thing with the entire
stoic system
however larry larry's attempt is
on one hand more comprehensive than mine
because he didn't focus just on the
pictures
just like the whole thing but it's also
much more
difficult in terms of you know it's not
as accessible to the general public
because he wrote for philosophers for
for you know in a technical fashion if
you don't have
at least a couple of courses of logic
under your belly you're not going to get
much out of that book
so so my attempt has been to
update stoicism to the 21st century but
also to make
pictures accessible again to a wider
public
because you know most people i bet today
don't haven't heard the term the
the word that you know the the name of
epictetus it's like uh who the hell was
this guy
people have heard plato people have
heard soccer these they've heard marcus
surrealists they might not have read
them
but they've heard of them epic theaters
like ap hebehu
uh and this is unfortunate
and it's also rather anomalous it is
like a 20th century early 21st century
feature because before that epictetus
was actually a household name
his school in necopolis in northwestern
greece was
very famous throughout antiquity you
know the emperor adrian
uh went to visit you know a lot of uh of
sort of high-level roman aristocrats
sent their kids to
study with him that sort of stuff then
throughout the middle ages and
renaissance the encouridion was actually
re-written and updated several times
because it was used
as a triangle as a
training manual for tranwall is a new
word that i just invented a training
manual
for christian monks right so it was
actually adopted by christianity
and then all the way to into sort of
very recent rather than recent times
like many of the uh american
founding fathers benjamin franklin
george washington thomas jefferson
as well as several major british figures
early modern british figures
such as david hume and adam smith they
all had copies of the anchor radio they
know
they all knew about epicurus whether
they considered themselves stoics or not
uh they certainly had read him so and so
i think it is unfortunate that
a lot of people today don't even know
what potatoes was i think his
his philosophy with or without my update
is is incredible and it needs to be you
know
understood and appreciated because it
changes lives
like a changed mind what's so special
about him
well he's a no-nonsense kind of
philosopher he talks
very in a very plain plain language he
talks about important topics
uh anything from from wealth to
friendship to death to
you know what are the important things
in life in fact even actually gives you
advice on uh what kind of conversation
to engage in
and whether to watch chariot races or
not should we should we watch chariot
races no we shouldn't watch
chariot races really it's like it's a
waste of time unfortunately there are
not many of those
yeah i know i love i just want to see a
a boudicca
you know i want to i want to see some
some horses and some
lions and tigers getting at it yeah
that'd be kind of interesting wouldn't
it
so so he's both straightforward and
approaches
a number of topics that are really about
concern for for everyday life
he also has a wicked sense of humor uh
bordering on
sarcasm uh you know he's by modern
standards he's a little bit abusive of
some of his students right he
calls him slaves which he would know
because he actually was a slave
you know he studied out his life in
hieropolis in western turkey modern
western turkey
as a slave in fact we don't even know
his real name epic
epic toss just means acquired in greek
it literally means that he was a slave
right so i only um i only learned
recently
that plato wasn't plato's real name that
it was that's right
aristocles that's right apparently we
don't know for sure but yes yeah and
plato
just means road shoulder yeah because he
was wrestling ah
now if you if you google it there was
three
um three suggestions for why he was
called plato plato is the broad
um first one is the breadth of his
shoulders
um potentially because of all of the
weight training he'd done through
wrestling uh in the gymnasium um the
second one is the breadth of his skills
again for going from the physical
attributes the third one
is the size of his forehead
oh that's interesting
which which are not actually mutually
exclusive right once one can have both
broad shoulders and a broad
understanding under broad forehead and i
brought forehead yes absolutely it could
be all of the above
right but the difference being that a
broad forehead is not the result of your
efforts on the other hand the other two
that really are
actually are right i get it so epictetus
why is he so cool
well it's cool because it gives you very
practical advice on life um for instance
if
if you pick up the first the very
opening of the anchor reading
uh it says some things are up to us
other things are not up to us
and then it gives uh two lists of things
that are and are not
under our power and if you actually if
if you get anything other than caridion
or of the field guide
the new the new version that would be it
if you just get that one and incorporate
it into your daily life
that's just just that one is going to
change things for you because
uh it turns out that what it does if you
really understand that the so-called
dichotomy this is a referred to as the
economy of control
if you understand the economy control
and incorporate it in your life and you
know
internalize it because understanding
it's easy sure some things are up to me
other things are not up to me right
okay then we can have we can have a
discussion about
what falls into each category and
actually we should have that discussion
because
it is important but understanding is now
it's not enough you have to internalize
it you have to actually live it
and if you do what that does is it
results into a
major reorientation of the way you
conduct your life
because it turns out that epictetus says
that the only things the things that are
up to us
actually very limited essentially three
categories of things that are up to us
our considered judgments our
endorsed values and our decisions to act
or knock to act
that's it nothing else right so not even
most of your mental life is under your
control as we know you know there's this
all sorts of thoughts that
pop up to in our mind and we can't
control them we don't even want to
control them necessarily right
but those three things are the ones you
control the rest you don't
you can influence it of course in some
cases but you don't control it don't you
control the out the
the outcome for instance we're talking
we're having this conversation with a
pandemic right
so let's talk about health health is one
of the things that a picture that says
it's not under your control
and a lot of people find that rather
counterintuitive it's like what do you
mean
i can go to the gym i can uh you know
exercise i can have a
healthy diet now that i undercove it i
can
uh you know wear a mask when i go out uh
social distance avoid crowds
wipe down my groceries and sanitize my
hands all that sort of stuff right
and you should do that in fact all those
things are under your control because
those are
your decisions to act and not to act
based on your judgments
right however i'm a biologist i can tell
you
viruses are sons of [ __ ] they they
will get you they might get you even if
you do everything right
right it's it's down to luck yes you can
influence that outcome meaning that if
you do everything right you're less
likely
probably far less likely to contract the
virus but you may
right all it takes is i go to the
grocery i have to go to grocery shopping
because i have to eat
and all it takes is somebody not wearing
their mask
sneezing uh you know a foot away from me
and that's it
then then i i got it right so
if we understand this then what happens
is that you start worrying much less
about outcomes because they're not under
your control not because they're not
important
it is important whether i get sick or
not from from covet right um but it's
not in my control so why the hell am i
worried about it
there's no it's a waste of energy it's a
waste of of mental energy and emotional
energy
i should focus on the other hand where
my agency is maximized where i can
actually make a difference
right in the kinds of judgments and
decisions that i was talking about
if you do that for everything in your
life because epithelium says you should
do that for
anything no matter it doesn't matter
what it is whether it's important or not
large or small et cetera he says
your life would change dramatically and
you would be
happy you would not complain you would
not be angry
with people and you would not be angry
at circumstances like okay
i sign up i i like that sort of stuff
and
it works it does take practice obviously
uh as i said one thing is to understand
the the the idea another thing is to
actually internalize it it takes a
little bit of practice but
i can i can tell you it started making a
difference in my life within weeks
after i started practicing stoicism and
now it's kind of second nature
that was something that i really enjoyed
during our first conversation which
everyone can go back and listen to from
earlier this year if you enjoyed this
conversation
um was talking about the automation of
it
um in the same way as people
automate the other things in their life
a little trigger
that reminds them to go outside the
trigger for the dichotomy of control
it's one thing to know it it's another
thing to internalize it and then it's a
third thing to automate it
and that gap between understanding how
to do it and what it is
and then the um removal of it being so
arduous that it takes tons and tons of
effort
uh is another step right and that's just
repetition
over time it is just repetition just
like a lot of other things you know if
you want to learn how to drive a car or
play an instrument or
you know anything uh repetition is the
key you have to understand what you're
doing i mean you have to
to have a sort of a cognitive
understanding of you know why is it that
you want to hit the brake
let's say if a pedestrian walks in front
of you all of a sudden
but understanding by itself doesn't
bring your ability to actually drive the
car
well or play the instrument well or do
whatever precisely
what is a vadde macomb
but if vader mecum is allowed did i
pronounce it correctly
yes yes you do yes uh vadim just means
um
bring it with you or carry with you
and that is the reason that you make a
book into something that's small
and that is with you at all times and
yeah that's cool i really like that
vader may come i'm gonna and it's it go
with you did you say
yeah it comes with me literally cool
so what are your favorite lessons you've
like you say not a small um undertaking
to try
and do stoicism 2.0 before we get on to
where you diverged and where you amended
work
what were some of the lessons your
favorite lessons that didn't require any
modification from the original text well
let's see we can open some kind of a
random
the first one i just told you the number
number one right
um number 11 i think it's particularly
uh
interesting it says it starts out my
version starts out you should go through
life as a traveler who stops at an end
never regarding anything is truly yours
but as on loan from the universe
and then it continues for a couple of
other paragraphs and that's a notion
that you find in epictetus
and in fact you actually find in earlier
stoics like seneca
this idea that we don't actually own
anything we use a language of ownership
for a lot of things
my house my wife my friend
my this and that or the other right but
in fact you don't own anything
even if you legally own your house it's
not really yours
meaning that somebody probably lived in
it before you did and somebody's going
to live
in it after you you you're go you're
done with it even if it's a new house at
some point somebody else will inherit it
or somebody else will will buy it it's
not something you can carry with you
into the
under the grave right and of course even
so more so
for uh things like relationships right i
mean nobody is actually you're no human
being is
yours you have a relationship with them
and the relationship
relationships change uh over time uh
sometimes the end
um and they are however an important
part of life
so if what peter is saying there is like
hold on to everything
as if you were a traveler in a hotel
right when you check in your hotel uh
the room that you're given
is your room quote unquote right not as
in
i own it and that's it i can do whatever
i want
i want with it i can't trash it i can
you know do do
do whatever i like no i don't i can't
but it is my room nobody else is going
to get into it
you know unless i give permission for
the duration of my stay now
what is the proper way to stay at hotel
you use everything you have available
but you don't trust the place you leave
it as you know clean and orderly as you
found it even better
actually ideally and so on and so forth
right i've never
left a hotel room better than i found it
massimo if that's the way that you
that might be your cultural heritage
speaking for you there but us brits are
nowhere near as
polite and tidy as that granted
that's not a normal thing but you see
what i mean you certainly wouldn't trash
it
right that's the the notion is so the
idea is that
that's the attitude that you should up
that you should have for pretty much
everything in life just
hold it lightly remember that it's not
yours it's on loan from the universe and
the universe can
take that lone back at any time wasn't
there a
um a little further down the line of
that particular thinking
wasn't there a place that you diverge
from the work
the original text whereby you had a
problem with the way that describing
dealing with the death of a family
member uh
was basically to be treated with
equanimity
it was like it doesn't matter like you
shouldn't cry if your wife or your son
or your daughter dies
you shouldn't cry if this happens and i
think that you said
that kind of we forget or that is
ignorant
of the way that interpersonal
relationships work is that right
so so what epictetus says this that's
actually one of the major places where i
diverge from
epictetus and i diverge with
respect and understanding uh not because
i thought it was an i think it was an it
was an idiot it's like oh look at the
kind of stuff that he was believing
so let me set the stage first the stoics
uh believed in uh a type of providence
which is not like the christian
providence you know christian providence
is based on the notion that there is a
creator god that loves us and cares
about us
and has a plan for the universe that's
not what we're talking about however
the stoics believe that the universe
itself
which they called god or nature
interchangeably
is a living organism endowed with logos
logos is the ability to reason
okay so it's it's its own organ it's
it's a thing it's this gigantic organism
that does its own thing we don't know
what
what exactly it does but it does its own
thing we are literally bits and pieces
of that organism
okay like like cells in the organism or
or organs in the organism in fact
epictetus uses a metaphor
that i find beautiful he says you know
imagine you're the
foot that has to step into the mud
if you think of it from the point of
view just the thought without realizing
you're connected to a whole organism
you say well this is disgusting i don't
want to step into the mud what the hell
yeah i rather take a shower i think i
really have a bathroom you know i don't
want the mat the mud
but if you understand that you are in
fact connected to a body the body has to
get home
and the only way to get home is to cross
a muddy path
then only you're going to do it because
it's your duty but you're going to be
happy to do it
because you're fulfilling you're
literally fulfilling the reason you're
the reason for your existence you're
allowing
the body to get home right if you
believe in that kind of conception of
the universe
then it follows as a picture says that
when something tragic happens to us or
something that other people think tragic
not only we should endure it and accept
it we should actually be happy about it
right it's well it's the concept of amur
fati love your fate
although the phrase comes from nietzsche
much later on and he was not a stoic
but that's essentially the idea right so
when he says
in the original and caridian look
remember when you kiss your child or
or your wife remember that they're
mortals they're but
therefore if they die you will not be
disturbed
people read this passage out of context
like what kind of a monster is this guy
like what do you mean psychopathic yeah
sage from
from back in the in the ancient times
yeah
right but they don't understand that if
if in context
that epithelia is absolutely right this
is no different
in fact from a christian who really
believes
that his now deceased you know father or
mother or loved one
is in heaven he should be happy i never
understood you know i grew up catholic
and i never understood even when i was a
catholic
why is it that so many people who
profess to profess to be christian
go to funerals of their own loved ones
and cry and desp
in desperation it's like so you think
the guy is in hell
because that could be the only the only
reason why you would be in desperation
but if you actually think
that he is in a better place that is
with god in the presence of god and all
that
you shouldn't not only you shouldn't be
upset you should actually celebrate
you know funerals should be parties like
all right and i'm coming you know i'll
join you in a few
in a little bit of time and like
compared to eternity even if you live a
long time
as a human being it's laughing so it's
like okay great let's celebrate
but they don't and i suspect that they
don't because a lot of people don't
actually believe deep down what
what they're saying to interject there
obviously your background
which a lot of the listeners might not
know is actually
evolutionary biology right that's right
you spent a lot of time doing
um there is our genetics are one hell of
a drug
and our genetic predispositions are
capable of
overpowering pretty much anything i
think and that includes faith
like the the inherent
um horror that we feel when a loved one
passes away
is like gravity it's that strong you
know
and to believe obviously the stoics
weren't privy to
the work of the evolutionary theory um
but i think you are right to highlight
the fact that
it's just it's inherently unrealistic
to expect humans to be able to transcend
their own nature
because of some clever cerebral trick
that we've taught ourselves oh well
don't forget about the dichotomy of
control like my daughter was
11 years old and the light of my life
like what do you expect this person to
do
yeah exactly so it is not impossible
in practice it's also not tenable in
theory anymore
because today you know move 18 centuries
forward from epictetus
uh look at modern biology and modern
physics and there is no reason to think
that the universe is anything like what
the stoics
thought it was it's not a living
organism and that would reason
it is a set of dynamic processes
regulated by what we call the laws of
nature
and yes we are bits and pieces of the
universe but not in any sense that we
are functional bits and pieces we're not
like the foot in the in
the organization we're just there and
the universe doesn't care one way or the
other
what happens to us is irrelevant to the
rest of the universe it's not like it's
we're causally connected in a very loose
way but it's not
that nothing like that could provide you
something like stoic providence which
means
i argue in the field guide uh to a happy
life that we should do away with amur
fatih
but this notion that i should love
my fate no matter what it is it's not
tenable anymore i understand and i
respect why it was tenable in epictetus
time
there was a beautiful notion of
providence that they have but i can't
buy
into that notion of providence so it's
got to go now
if you suggest that and immediately
somebody says oh but then you give up
stoicism it's like well no hold on first
of all
in the introduction to book i explain
that
change within the stoic system is
nothing new even the ancient stocks
themselves constantly debated about what
stays and what goes
all right um clients the second head of
the store disagree with zeno
the first head of the store chrysippo is
the third head of the store disagree
with both
xeno and clients seneca
actually writes explicitly it's like
look
he writes a beautiful letter to his
friend lucillus and he says
look my friend the people that came
before us are not our masters they're
our teachers
they're our guides but if i find a new
way to proceed that it's better
i'll do it because you know the truth it
says is open to all and
and will be uncovered by future
generations so
so this notion that stoicism is like
this thing that was stable over time for
five centuries and then all of a sudden
you know who the hell are you to change
it
like no that's that's fantasy uh it has
never been stable
that said of course there is only a
certain amount of change you do
you can do and then still call it
stoicism i mean to some extent it
doesn't matter what we call it
right because names are names labels are
labels
um but i am sensitive to this notion
that you know if you change too much and
especially if you change too much
without
readjusting the bits and pieces of the
system without
seeking coherence within the system then
then you're open to the
uh to the accusation i suppose that it's
not stoicism anymore
that's why i do it very carefully you'll
notice that at the end of the of the
book there is an actual
actual detail table and there is a
section which i described bit by bit all
the changes that
that i made and why they were made and
how they fit into the general system
so one of the reasons this is still
stoicism is in my mind
uh well there's two reasons first of all
because the stoics insisted
that the three parts of philosophy
ethics which is about how to live your
life
metaphysics they call it physics but
metaphysics that under your
understanding of how the universe works
and logic meaning your ability to reason
they have to go together
because if you are if you don't reason
correctly about things
you're likely to mislead your life your
ethics isn't going to work very well
and if you are under deep
misunderstandings about how the
universe work works that also implies
that you're going to
likely mislead your life right
so the three things are connected if i
change the metaphysics in this case i'm
suggesting a change in the metaphysics
right do away with the notion that the
universe is a living organism and that
would reason
then you have to change the ethics which
is what i do you
you throw throw out the ammo fatty and
you retain what
well you still retain uh notions that
come out of the dichotomy of control
you still retain this idea that okay
maybe i'm not gonna love my faith
but i can't i can prepare myself
mentally to deal with things that are
inevitable
and accept them as for what for what
they are and still try to get the best
out of
life as it actually happens to me and
not as i would like it
to be right so not engaging in wishful
thinking so you're still
using adopting a stoic attitude you're
still adopting a lot of stoic
metaphysics because stoic metaphysics
includes determinism
that these were these people were
compatibilist as they we would say today
about
free will uh these people were
determined uh where uh
believed in universal cause and effect
we still do
modern science essentially is based on
the notion that
uh there's universal cause and effect
and they were materialists
meaning that they believe that the only
things that exist are are
physical stuff it's it's not we today
would say matter and energy of course
but stuff not you know there's no
transcendental thing there is no
in immaterial thing there's nothing out
there
um that along those lines those are
still true
as far as i can tell and and so that's
why you just we're still retaining much
of the stoic system but we're making
some
changes i like it how do you think the
stoics would define
a happy life obviously this is the stoic
guide to a happy life
we need to define our terms what is a
happy life
yeah the word happiness of course is
fraught with problems because
people have different very very
different ideas about what counts as a
happy life right
in fact the word happiness itself uh can
take a number of
meanings on one hand for instance i can
say oh i'm happy that tonight i get to
uh relax with my wife and watch a movie
sure but that's not the happiness that
we're talking about here
it's it the word applies but not in the
broader sense in a broader
sense happiness could be a life of
flourishing
a life where you get to enjoy the good
things about it your your
amount of pain and suffering is reduced
to a minimum
you pursue your projects etc etc right
that would be the aristotelian
version of the happy life what this the
the
the
word that we should use we should be
using actually is the one that the
ancient greeks used
regardless of which school they belonged
to and that was judah mania
eudaimonia is the life worth living okay
that seems very circular what's a happy
life a life worth living okay what's a
life worth living
right except that what breaks the
circularity is that each one of those
different schools had an actual
conception
of what counts as your demonic life and
why
lay it on us lay down this muscle let me
give you three
let me give actually let me give you
four um
including the stoic one because that
actually kind of gives gives you
um a very i think i hope a very clear
understanding of not only what the
ancient greeks and women thought but
actually how to think about
the happy life so aristotle
thought that a happy life was a life of
virtuous flourishing
virtuous flourishing means you want to
act virtuously meaning you want to be an
ethical human being
and however you also do need need
not just prefer but need certain
external things such as
health well a little bit of wealth a
little bit of
education a little bit of good looks and
like things like that otherwise your
life sucks even if you're virtuous your
life sucks
that's aristotle uh the epicureans
thought that the good life is actually
defined by one thing and one thing only
and that is
absence of pain okay a good human life
no matter you can
you can live your life in a number of
different ways so long as it's painless
particularly in terms of emotional pain
okay
so that's true the cynics cynics were
the in-your-face
philosophers of antiquity that the
people that you know went in the streets
and
and and reminded people constantly how
bad that they were
and the cynics thought that the only
thing that matters is virtue
health doesn't matter wealth doesn't
matter possessions don't matter
that nothing else matters the only thing
about what what makes a good human life
is acting virtuously active why
we would say today pro socially so
engage with other people in a in a
pro-social fashion
and then there is the stoics the stoics
kind of fall
in between the aristotelians and the
cynics
so the stoic said yes the the
overarching thing that is important you
know the
the top thing that it's important in
life is to act ethically toward other
people
why because that's human nature human
nature is the nature of a cooperative
social being yes we do nasty things to
each other
on occasion yes we use violence yes we
cheat yes with all that but those are
actually
negative aspects of human nature that
get in the way
of social social life fundamentally for
the stoics we're essentially social
beings and we depend on each other in a
very interconnected
fashion in order to have a good life so
the most important thing is in fact to
act ethically toward other people
but it's okay to also pursue undecide so
to speak
uh the kinds of things that aristotle
thought were absolutely necessary for
life such as
wealth self-education uh et cetera et
cetera because other things being equal
it's better to be healthy than
sick better to be wealthy than poor
better be educated and ignorant and that
sort of stuff
but the crucial difference with
aristotle is that the stoics thought
that even if you don't have any of those
things
your life is still worth living and the
reason for that
is because it is still in your power
to do good in in in in life to do good
to other people even if you are sick
even if you're poor even if you are you
know if your means are very limited
so let me give you an example of a good
stoic life even though the person that
i'm about to mention
was not actually a stoic um nelson
mandela
so we all know that mandela spent i
forgot what it was
18 years i think in prison during the
apartheid regime
that's not flourishing i just thought it
would have said
sorry dude your life sucks right it's
like that is definitely not flourishing
so with the
epicureans yeah they would have said
your answer said yeah that's a lot of
pain my friend
the both physical and mental pain so
know your life sucks as an epicurean as
well
but the stoics would say uh hold on
yes of course you're not flourishing of
course you're not
you know you're not enjoying the the the
kinds of material life that other people
might be enjoying but
you're doing something that is very
worthwhile you're fighting for a good
cause
you're fighting for improving the human
condition
uh therefore your life is worth living
even if you don't succeed because in the
end
as we know he actually succeeded in the
end but even if you don't succeed
epictetus actually mentions
some people who lost their lives uh in
opposition to the emperors of vespasian
and the mission
who the stoics considered uh you know
tyrants
and if it is one of his students at one
point says
well that was a wasted life right what
what was the point of that
and the peter says he gave the example
it was like the purple and the toga the
purple in the toga is the
is the the the thing that actually makes
you look at at the
the whole garment and say okay that's
interesting that's uh that's uh
that's well done right so a life
like nelson mandela's even if had
he had failed it would have seen still
been
worthwhile because it would have set the
example for others
on on what to do and how to live your
life so all of these different
conceptions
are the result of different
understandings of what's important about
human nature
right so what breaks the circle that you
brought up
is that um the the the claim is not just
that the happy life is the life worth
living that would definitely be circular
that would definitely not you know
now the the the the idea is the happy
life is the life worth living and here
it is and here's how i cash it out
and why right i like it i i
i'm worried and um thankful
that we are revisiting ancient wisdom on
modern wisdom
and generally kind of in the 21st
century because it seems like so many of
the things that people presume are going
to make them happy have become hijacked
you know like the instagram
tick tock 21st century transactional sex
pornhub world of
of um the race to the bottom of the
brain stem which you'll be familiar with
from evolutionary psychology which is
how a lot of the apps that people spend
a lot of time on uh
getting them hooked uh you know it
really does feel like
this is a little bit of an antidote to
that so hopefully that's
opened some people's eyes to it in terms
of
some strategies or your favorite
strategies
on route to the happy life we've got the
dichotomy of control which is
um i would say perhaps
more useful at avoiding suffering and
pain
than perhaps it is at pursuing happiness
i might have got that a little bit wrong
but that's
at least how it seems to me if if you
see
pain as being in the way of happiness as
opposed to
it it removes the negatives rather than
adds the positives
to me as far as that seems i'm gonna
disagree with that on that
with you on that one a little bit i mean
i can see why you say that uh
because yes one of one of the major
outcomes one of the major goals of the
economic control is in fact
to as epithelius puts it do not get
disturbed
when events don't go your way right uh
so that's
i can see where that comes from but at
the same time there is also the positive
you know the flip side of the coin
is um you don't get disturbed the notion
of not getting disturbed by
but the fact that events don't always go
your way
that's because that's one side of the
one half of the dicamba control
it's because you're focusing on the
things that you don't control right you
say okay i don't control this
so i shouldn't be worried about it i
should activate i should
actively cultivate a attitude of
equanimity toward
outcomes because i don't control the
outcomes but that's only half of the
economy
the other half is and i should be
focusing my
energy and efforts on the stuff that i
actually control
now it turns out as we all realize
there's a pretty damn good correlation
between your efforts and your outcomes
right so let me go back to the initial
example of the covet
infection right um while it is true that
i don't control the outcome
that i could still get covered no matter
what i do and no matter how careful i am
it is also equally true that my chances
of getting covered go
dramatically down because i'm doing all
those kind of things
that that um that i'm doing vice versa
in terms of
of positive outcomes because that would
be a negative outcome obviously
but in terms of positive outcomes i
don't know if i'm
applying for a job for instance right uh
yeah if i focus on the outcome which is
actually getting the job
i'm focusing on the wrong thing
according to a picture this because
that's not up to me that's up to whoever
is interviewing me
right however focusing on the effort
putting together a resume focusing
during the interview
dressing well not going out drinking the
night before the interview you know that
all that sort of stuff
those are up to me and those obviously
raise significantly the chances that i
will in fact get the job
right so so there is actually a positive
aspect to it um
and it's essentially uh you know we also
mentioned this this bit
on on 11 on section 11 of the book about
going through life as a as if you were
in a an
in a checking in a hotel
there too another analogy that the
historics use
is the seasonal um
uh the seasonal way of thinking
so epictetus says for instance don't
don't wish for figs in winter wishing
for things in winter
is hopeless because figs are not winter
you know they don't bloom in winter they
don't they're not winter fruits
i can tell i'm a botanist and um on the
other hand
don't we not wishing for figs in winter
anyone would he applies this to you know
missing your loved ones
if if your parents died for instance as
in my case a few years ago
wish them to wish that they were here
now is wishing for figs in winter
it's like okay i'm just making myself
feeling bad because
now i'm now i'm my mind is on purpose
going
on another direction where which is not
it's not uh it's not a
productive one however they there was a
season during which they were
alive and well right there was a summer
there
and so the notion is that the con so the
other side of
the coin the flip side of the coin is
and when it's summer you really should
enjoy the fix
because they are in season right so the
uh
the the upshot of this is that stoics
tend to concentrate on the focus under
here and now
of what they have now we try not to
regret things that
we no longer have because they're gone
we try not to hope too much for things
to come because they're also not under
my control i mean who knows what the
hell is going to happen
but in the meantime i can focus on what
i have right here right now i have
a good life i'm healthy i have a wife
that loves me i have a daughter
that is uh starting her life as an
independent although i have friends
you know there are all these things that
eventually will be gone
right at some point or another but why
the hell should i worry about the fact
that they're gonna be
gone when they're gonna garner god
that's it okay fine and the story that's
how life works but right now they're
here
and so i need to pay attention to here
now because too often we actually take
people and things
for granted and we can also take
ourselves out of the moment of enjoying
the brief time that we do have with
those people and things worrying about
the time when they're not going to be
here and that's a surefire route to
misery
that's like uh the mark twain quote
which is worrying is like playing a debt
that you don't owe
yes exactly that's exactly right mark
twain had
a little bit of a stoic good obviously
i've done my research on mark so i i
know that precisely
um in terms of one more
lesson that you think you didn't need to
change
but would help people to lead a happy
life what would it be
number 30 you're a social animal and
whether you like it or not
living in a society comes with certain
duties how do you figure out what these
duties are
just look at the various roles you play
so this is this comes out of what is
sometimes referred to as epictetus role
ethics
uh there's a wonderful book about just
about that aspect of stoicism over the
patriarchs philosophy by brian johnson
who is a colleague of mine at
fordham university and he wrote a book
on the rolatex of epicurus
the notion that it is put forth is that
like look
what's your best guidance in life and
how to actually live your life well just
ask yourself what kind of roles you
normally play
and he distinguished three types of
roles that we all
have in life the first and most
fundamental one is of course the member
of the human cosmopolis we are human
beings
all of us right and since the stoics
were cosmopolitan
uh the implication of that is that we
should never do anything that undermines
the human cosmopolis what do what do you
mean by cosmopolitan in in this
definition
uh considering every human being on
earth as brothers and sisters
all right so which means you should
never do anything that undermines the
human cosmopolis now whenever i say that
often people say i can't even if i
wanted to i can't undermine you most
modeling i don't have that kind of
power right i'm not an emperor i'm not a
president of the united states
but that's not true uh for instance if
um
if you live a the kind of life that
contributes to global warming
you are undermining the the the human
cosmopolis
if you live if you shop let's say
for your daily life into places that are
known to exploit other people you're
undermining
the human cosmopolis if you are eating
animals that have suffered unnecessarily
in order to be
uh served on your dinner plate you are
undermining the human cosmopolitan so
you know there's all sorts of ways you
can actually undermining your
cosmopolitans
so that's number one the first first
roll the other two classes or roles
are the the types of roles that
circumstances
give you you don't choose them for
instance you know you're somebody's
son right you didn't choose that that
was not your choice that's that's what
it is
but now that you're there you have some
duties you know
uh children have certain duties toward
their parents
uh even if epithelius says even if their
parents are not good
they're you know they're not the best
parents you can because the deal that
the universe gave you wasn't
i'm gonna give you the best parents the
universe just said i'm gonna give you
parents
and you know sometimes you it works out
well sometimes it doesn't but the point
is
your parents behavior is not under your
control your behavior is under your
control
so you still have certain duties now
those duties don't expand to
you know being abused physically or
mentally by your parents that's not
that's not a duty that you have but you
do have a duty to be forgiving a duty to
be helpful
etc etc and then the third class of
duties
of roles sorry sorry are the the ones
that we
choose given our circumstances for
instance i'm a father that was a choice
uh i'm a friend to some people and and
that's another choice
uh my career was a choice to some extent
and so on and so forth right my
obviously my relation to my wife was a
choice all of those
carry their own duties so if i
put somebody in into the into the world
then i have certain duties toward that
person
i have to take care of that person i
have to you know make sure that
she has as many instruments as possible
to actually live a fulfilling life
if i am in a relationship with my
partner
that carries certain other duties and
again
those duties don't imply necessarily
that the other person just replicates
or reciprocates on the same level i mean
i'm lucky enough actually that
you know my friends and relatives and
and and uh uh
you know loved ones actually do then to
to reciprocate
but sometimes they they won't sometimes
that that's not the case and epithelia
says
it doesn't matter because other people's
behaviors is not under your control
and seneca says that when it comes to
what the ancients call benefits so being
generous
giving giving to other people he says
the
the thing to do is always to have your
ledger
such that you owe you give more than you
receive
right so don't look at what you're
getting look at what you're doing
what you're giving and of course once
again this
the the two are often connected without
being
pollyannish about this kind of stuff but
look if you're a generous person who
actually genuinely loves other people
and wants to be
that typically the people realize that
and typically people will give back
precisely because as the stoic say human
beings tend to be social
and highly pro pro you know interactive
and interdependent of each other
i think that we agree on something
that other people got angry at me for
talking about on a podcast
a little while ago and okay
can we just take a second to talk about
how much bollocks is in the secret
oh yes a lot so
the the cur the best lies have a kernel
of truth in them right
and what you've just brought up there
with the
what you could quite easily call karma
like
things come back around right but
there isn't some metaphysical magnetized
aura of nebulous ephemeral
supercharged good teons or whatever they
were called in the bot in the secret
i was about to call it the bollocks
there but um
in the secret uh and yet
because of that kernel of truth it
seduces people into believing it
right that's that's exactly i mean
that's how a lot of pseudoscience works
that there is a kernel of truth there is
a kernel of plausibility
right and people don't think too
carefully about it
they also engage in a lot of wishful
thinking it's like oh that sounds good
so i want to believe it i mean
you know that that that that's how the
psychology of pseudoscience
science actually works but yeah actually
i've used the secret
as an example of a type of metaphysics
that is entirely incompatible with
stoicism
because it violates the economy of
control essentially it says that you do
control the universe
that if you really want it if you really
make the effort if you really are into
certain things the universe somehow will
rearrange itself
um so to you know favor uh your your
goals
epictetus expl who had not read of
obviously the secret
thank god for that right explicitly says
so to one of his students um he says um
money students apparently came in
complaining about the fact that his nose
was
was running all the time right so he had
a cold or something like that
and if he says okay wipe your damn nails
but stop complaining about the fact that
there are such a things as running noses
in the universe what do you want to do
the uni
literally says what would you want the
universe to rearrange yourself for the
sake of your running nose it's like
when i read that i said wait a minute
this guy must have read that the secret
yeah him and rhonda byrne would have
fallen out
i remember man the um there's this story
do you remember
it was about 2003 the big
christmas day suit a boxing day tsunami
in thailand was it
yeah in east asia and rhonda byrne
author of the secret
said the reason that the tsunami
happened was because the people
of east asia were giving out bad energy
that attracted the tsunami right that's
awful
in what in what world is that acceptable
to say
hundreds of thousands of people
displaced from their homes and then
some bourgeois writer sitting at the
back of a couple of millions sold
copies of a book that is based on
[ __ ]
is able to say oh well if only you'd
been giving off
some more positive vibes then this
tsunami wouldn't have come and
annihilated the next
generation yeah no i'm completely on
board with with that in fact
not only i think that metaphysic
remember we were discussing earlier that
according to the strikes
logic metaphysics and ethics are
connected
yeah i love the um i love the fields i
love the ring
the fence around the field analogy that
you gave i think right exactly very nice
yeah
well think about in terms of the secret
they're connecting exactly the wrong way
right because the metaphysics is
[ __ ]
i mean the universe simply doesn't work
that way the logic is
flawed because clearly you should be
able to realize that the universe
doesn't work that way and draw the right
conclusions
and the ethics is horrible because it
ends up
blaming the victims as in the case of
the tsunami that you just
brought up right so oh it's their fault
what do you mean it's their fault those
people are there
they're suffering some of them died as a
result of a random natural
event and you're saying that it's their
fault essentially
what kind of monstrous ethics it really
is do you know what it is identifying
the fact that it is the
flipped reverse of the dichotomy of
control
uh i mean if ever there needed to be a
nail in the coffin
of the secret it could be right there do
you know what it is as well i had one of
the guys on i'm gonna forget his name
i had one of the guys that featured in
the film the secret um
really smart cognitive psychologist
understood what he was talking about
and he it felt like was in it
begrudgingly or perhaps for clout
and even him this is a person who
featured in the film very prominently
and even he had highlighted his own
issues we can continue badmouthing the
secret for the remainder of the episode
but i feel like we've
we can we can just summarize it this way
the metaphysics is [ __ ] the
reasoning is bad and the headaches is
horrible
there we go that's it job done um
last lesson another one where you
diverge from stoicism something else
that you think would help people uh lead
a happy life
you talk about 50 you're talking about
52 whichever you think oh
oh i thought i thought you literally
thought the last lesson no no
a final lesson from you massimo um
i think uh let's see there are there are
several of course that are
um that are interesting to me in that
sense but
for instance um
i tend to go back over and over on this
notion
of
one thing that that is missing from the
original stoicism
is an appreciation of what we would
today call social justice
right and i don't mean as in social
justice warriors or anything like that i
just mean the basic concept in
philosophy for social justice meaning
that
we should try to come up with a society
that is as just as
equanimous as possible right stoicism
doesn't have that and it's not a fault
necessarily because stoicism is a
personal philosophy it's not meant to be
a you know broad societal level kind of
umbrella
type of philosophy for instance when
people accuse the story so but you don't
have a theory of social justice or
anything like that
well would you ever accuse christians or
buddhists of the same
buddhism doesn't have a theory of social
justice neither does christianity
because those are personal philosophies
they tell you how you should behave not
how other people should behave
however it is still the case
that uh the ancient stoics started
moving in that direction
and i think that it behooves us to keep
moving along the same trajectory let me
give you two examples
the stoics where the ancient stories i'm
talking
were fairly unusual in the ancient world
because they thought that women
are have the same mental abilities as
men and therefore they actually ought to
study philosophy and practice the
virtuous life
right seneca says that explicitly uh
epithelius said that explicitly they're
they're
it's there okay but of course they were
not what we would call feminists
uh you know in modern terms i mean they
wear you know seneca and fat
on the one hand says this kind of stuff
very explicitly there's no there's no
this is not even implied this is he
actually says so explicitly in
a letter of consolation that he writes
to his friend marsha who had lost
an adult son at some point
he says you know you you think that i'm
talking out of
steps here because you're a woman but in
fact women have the same ability as men
they should be et cetera et cetera so he
actually says that but then you know
like a few paragraphs later he's like
you know don't be womanish don't be
you know it's like so it was not too har
actually in a different letter
don't be womanish okay what do you mean
hey hold on a second here
so seneca and the stoics moved and
started moving in that direction but of
course they were
naturally a product of their own culture
and time
and these these were people that lived
2000 years ago in an incredibly
misogynistic society by by modern
standards right
so money stoics can pick up on that and
there are actually a couple of scholars
written in technical papers about the
relationship between stoicism and
feminism for instance
feminism here understood very simply and
very broadly i'm not talking about
specific waves or specific
you know uh current ongoing controversy
i'm simply talking about the basic
notion that
women are human beings just as men and
therefore they ought to
have the same rights and and etc that's
it that's that's what i'm talking about
uh so there is more modern scholarship
that moves us in that direction it's
an argues and i agree that feminism in
that bare-bones sense that i just
mentioned is actually logically entailed
by stoic philosophy and so the story
should be feminist
it's inconsistent to for somebody to be
a stoic and not not being a feminist
the second example has to do with the
environment so the ancient stories were
not of course conscious of
the value of the environment in which in
the way in which we are right
in fact explicitly they thought that
what we call
the environment particularly other
animals and plants are there for our
consumption
they're there because you know the logos
of the universe set it up in a way that
that's what we're going to do with it
however they did have
these notion of the expanding circles of
concern one of the uh second century
stoics his name was
haeroplus said that we should try
to practice this notion of of expanding
our concern
we're naturally concerned about
ourselves that comes natural to a human
being right
it's the self but then it also comes
pretty natural immediately early on in
our lives to be concerned
with our caretakers you know typically
our parents
and then we expand that kind of concern
to other family members and friends
and then he said we should make an
effort to expand that kind of concern
to further and further circles out there
citizens of their same city citizens of
the same country and eventually humanity
at large
right well today some scholars modern
scholars in this tourism like chris gill
for instance
uh say yeah and there is one more step
and then one more in fact a couple more
steps
the the immediate obvious step after
that is other sentient animals
because why because they suffer because
they're capable of suffering
and then after that so the environment
as a whole but not in
any kind of again pollyanna's shorts or
gaia kind of sense in which she's oh
well wishy washy
no just because we we depend on a
healthy environment
uh to as human beings to live so it's
it's up to us
it's the same version it's an expanded
version of the same concept that the
stoics have
uh but which is one of the things i one
of the reasons why i really like
stoicism
we tend today to make a sharp
distinction between self
and and self-regard you know and
and other regard right so you if you're
an altruist you're doing something that
sacrifices yourself to for
for the sake of another the stoics
didn't see it that way
the stoics thought that whenever you
help other people you're actually
helping yourself because you're making
yourself a better person
and whenever you're working on becoming
a better person you're automatically
helping other people because that's
you know that's that's the way your
interactions are gonna go and so
similarly
they wouldn't see i think a sharp
distinction today
with modern scientific knowledge between
ourselves and environment of course you
want to
safeguard the environment because our
own damn survival depends on it
our ability to flourish depends on it
the reason you want
good hair and good quality water for
everybody is because
that's how you you live a good life
otherwise you're gonna literally poison
yourself
so you should you should be concerned
with it so those are some of the things
that also that i
expect it's not not as much as a
disagreement with epic theater as much
as an expansion
of epithelius concerns i think that it's
really interesting to hear the
way that you can synthesize new world
information you know and and adapt it to
ancient wisdom i really i'm intrigued by
what you said at the very beginning
that i it hadn't come to me that
stoicism
had this you know half millennia or so
to develop
and then very quickly got muted by the
new kid on the block which was
christianity
for about a thousand years and then came
back renaissance then
really sort of kicked on enlightenment
then stopped again and now
you people like yourself and ryan
holiday so on and so forth are
repopularizing it um but i wonder
i wonder what we would have
if stoicism had been allowed to
continue unfettered or even a couple of
schools of it you know had been able to
keep going for
1500 years it would have been very
interesting yeah we would have something
similar to
modern buddhism we would have a number
of schools of thought
some of them would put would probably
have developed certain strands of
ancient thought into new directions and
others would have picked up enough
other strands and some of them might
even become incompatible i mean there
are some versions of modern buddhism
that you could argue are actually
incompatible with each other
even though they all come from the same
root their emphasis their development as
being such
that they are actually not compatible
and that's great because
that means that there is more variation
you know there is more
to pick from in terms of when you're
thinking about your philosophy of life
you say okay well there's different ways
of thinking about this stuff and you
know let me see which one
uh actually resonates with me and which
one is actually useful to me
yeah i really love that quote and i'd
written it down and then you said it so
i could i couldn't say it
uh those who have advanced these
doctrines before us are not our masters
but our guides
from seneca and with that as well is a
lovely way to kind of remind us all that
the vast majority of what i spend my
time thinking about talking about on the
show which is how to lead a good life
and
how to be virtuous and be happy and be
fulfilled is an ongoing process
there is wisdom of the past that we can
take in
and think oh my god this is there's so
much of the work has been done already
but there's a massive amount of imposter
syndrome
uh or over uh over respect
i guess for the sages of the pastor
presumed that there's no more work
to be done on top of that so the stoic
guide
to a happy life will be linked in the
show notes below if you've enjoyed today
i
highly highly recommend that you go and
check it out very easy book to read what
we are
150 pages pocket sized your vader may
come
to take with you uh anywhere else that
people should go and check out massimo
well if anybody's interested in pretty
much everything i do from podcasting to
writing essays and books uh they can go
to massimo piluchi.com
i imagine that was a very easy url to
get
yes no one else competing for that
matter it's a little bit more difficult
to spell
but it's it's it'll be linked there's a
link in the show notes below do not i
implore you you will
lose brain cells trying to write it
yourself just
click the link below it's been a
pleasure to have you on twice in 2020
mate i'm looking forward to the next
time thank you
[Music]